hello and welcome to M coding where we
try to get just a little bit better at
programming every episode I'm James
Murphy I'm using an experimental editor
theme today so let me know if it's
better or worse than usual
today we're talking about the algorithm
that I affectionately call fastpal if
you're a long time viewer you might
remember that I've had a video about
efficient exponentiation before that
video is more about how to find the
least number of multiplications possible
to raise something to a small power
fastpal on the other hand is a general
algorithm to raise things to very large
powers of course if there's a fastpal
there's probably a slow pow and that's
the one you'd probably come up with on
your first try
to raise x to the nth power we start
with one and multiply by x n times that
means it takes n multiplies overall in
order to raise something to the nth
power
the idea for fastpau is that x to the N
is approximately equal to x to the N
over 2 squared
if n is even that's exactly correct
and event is odd then we just need to
multiply by another single X this is
great because it phrases the answer to
the problem what's x to the n in terms
of the solution to what's x to the N
over 2 a problem of half the size This
lends itself to a very simple and
elegant recursive solution
so let's see how to turn this into
fastpal we start off with our base case
which is that raising something to the
zeroth power always gives one
feel free to argue in the comments about
whether this does the right thing for x
equals zero if you disagree you could
always raise an exception we're going to
need half the value of N and the
remainder after division by two bit of
python trivia though if you need both
the quotient and remainder this is not
the best way to do it python has this
built in called div mod that gives you
both the quotient and remainder at the
same time
if you're wondering why python would
have a single function that gives you
both the quotient and remainder instead
of just expecting you to use divide by
two and then mod 2. a lot of integer
long division algorithms like the one
that you learned in school produce the
remainder as sort of just a byproduct of
the algorithm
so if you computed and divided by
something you actually get n mod the
same something for free
of course bitwise operations also work
since we're using two here but in
general even if you're not using two
divmod can give you both at the same
time moving on WE recursively compute X
to half the power
then square that answer and multiply by
x one more time if there was a remainder
otherwise just return the result
it's simple there's a great core idea
it's very elegant and it's pretty easy
to code up this is something you could
learn as your first recursive algorithm
by the way other people call this
algorithm exponentiation by squaring uh
but that's a pretty lame name so I'm
going to call it fastpal
so anyway instead of using n
multiplications it only uses about login
multiplications there are plenty of ways
that you could take this code and tweak
it to go slightly faster and that's not
really the direction that I want to take
this in
after all python already has a built-in
exponentiation operator and as you could
probably guess fastpal is not that fast
compared to it although that's due in
part to the fact that the built-in
exponentiation operator uses fastpal or
some more sophisticated modification of
it know the direction that I want to
take this in is what if we allow X to be
something other than an integer and what
if we allow a different kind of
multiplication this idea and this
algorithm don't really depend on
integers or multiplication and
recognizing this allows fastpow to be a
more General algorithm
will still stick to non-negative integer
Powers but other than that let's see
what else we actually used
so let's just parameterize this function
by the kind of multiplication that we
want to do we'll do this by adding two
new arguments multiply and identity
we'll use multiply in place of anywhere
that we were going to use the star
operator
and we'll use identity in place of 1
because 1 was really specific to
integers
so if we raise something to the zeroth
power we need to return the identity
instead of one
the division here is division of the
power n not of the X so that is still
integer division
we can still recursively fast pow
but we can't use star equals here
star equals is effectively just saying
result is result times result that's
squaring the value
so let's replace squaring the value with
multiplying the value with itself
same thing goes here instead of using
the star operator to multiply we'll use
the mole operator to multiply
and don't forget to pass the new
arguments here
now in order to use our more General
fastpal we need to Define this
multiplication and identity
if we wanted to check our implementation
we could Define our multiplication
function to just take two arguments and
use the built-in multiplication the
identity for this is the one that we had
here before
it now and all of our asserts pass
1 to the power one hundred is one
5 cubed is 125.
and 2 to the 11th is 2048. so what other
kinds of multiplications and identity
can I pass in
we just need a multiplication where
we're allowed to put parentheses
wherever we want
that's called associativity the other
property that we used is that
multiplying by the identity doesn't
change the value
we actually don't care about
commutativity because we're always
multiplying by the same number
reordering them doesn't change anything
so we need associativity and an identity
element
well instead of multiplication another
associative operator that we have is
addition
it doesn't matter where you put the
parentheses when you do addition of
integers
but one is not the element that does
nothing for addition
if we want adding something to do
nothing then we should use zero well
then what's fastpal going to give us in
this case
1 to the power 100 is giving us 100
5 to the power 3 is giving us 15.
and 2 to the 11 is giving us 22.
read those numbers again and you realize
that it's actually just doing regular
multiplication that's right fast bow on
addition gives multiplication 1 times
100 is 100 5 times 3 is 15 and 2 times
11 is 22.
this is happening because although we
named it how for power like
multiplication what we're really doing
is repeated application
so repeated application of
multiplication is exponentiation but
repeated application of addition is
multiplication
if I repeatedly add 5 to itself three
times that's the same as 5 times 3.
let's test your intuition if we still
took multiplication to mean the built-in
plus operator
and we took our identity to be the empty
string
then what would the empty string to the
power 100 be
what would a to the 11 be
and what would ABC cubed be
answer coming in 3 2 1
the empty string to the 100 is the empty
string
a to the 11 is 11 A's
and ABC cubed is just ABC ABC ABC Once
Again repeated addition is basically
giving us a form of multiplication
multiplication for Strings means repeat
this that many times this is even
consistent with Python's built-in
multiplication so if you've ever
wondered why a hundred times the empty
string is even allowed
hopefully this gives you an idea that
it's because there's some deeper
underlying structure there
so I mean cool story bro but is this
actually useful for anything
so far we've seen a slower version of
the built-in exponentiation operator for
integers and an even slower version of
the multiplication operator for integers
and for Strings
there's pretty much no way that we're
going to be able to build the speed of a
python built in using something in pure
python
so we need to think about expensive
operations that are not built into
python
you got it here's an example I think
you're really going to like let's start
by importing numpy
then let's take our multiplication to be
convolution
convolution is an extremely important
operation especially in Signal
processing and it has a lot of the same
properties that the basic multiplication
does
in particular it is associative
but there's a problem
if you've ever looked at the Wikipedia
article for convolution you'll see all
kinds of mathematical jargon about
something called an approximation to the
identity why doesn't Wikipedia just tell
me what the identity is for the
multiplication
well that's because there is no identity
for convolution at least not for real
numbers
now technically we're on a computer and
the discrete convolution does actually
have an identity
but for this example we're going to be
modeling something continuous and the
continuous convolution does not have an
identity so it'd be kind of susque to
use the discrete version of the identity
for convolution here if we can we should
just not use an identity so first we
need to modify our algorithm
if you had an identity the kind of
algebraic structure we were working with
before is called a monoid but we can
actually get away with even less
if there's no identity like there isn't
for convolution then we can still do
fastpal we just need to change our base
case this is called a semi-group
structure by the way if you just have
associativity and not necessarily even
an identity so we change our base case
we now no longer allow raising to the
zeroth power we just assume or raise an
exception if you want that the smallest
power that we're going to feed to this
function is One X to the power one is
just X that one is always available once
again division here is division of the
power and the power is an integer we no
longer have to pass the identity and
voila our fastpow is now complete and in
its most general form as long as you're
not raising to the power zero this is
still going to give all the same answers
as before but now we no longer have to
specify an identity now let's get back
to the convolution
we no longer need the identity
then I'm going to take some samples and
use a discrete approximation of the
uniform distribution between 0 and 1.
let's pull in matplotlib and plot it
when we plot it we just see a flat line
which is what we expect because it's the
uniform distribution every point is as
likely as every other point
now get ready for the very cool surprise
what do we get when we use convolution
as our multiplication
and raise the uniform distribution to
the 30th power
are you ready
well what do you know doesn't that look
familiar
doesn't that just look so much like a
bell curve and there's no tricks here
there's no e to the minus x squared
anywhere inside you can run the example
yourself
let's put that in a loop and see it go
slowly
at n equals zero we just see the uniform
distribution
then we see a triangle and then each
subsequent convolution seems to give
something more and more normal
distribution like albeit shifting
further and further to the right and
getting squished and the really cool
fact is that this doesn't even depend on
using the uniform distribution you could
pick any initial distribution that you
want
here I just took some random formula 2x
minus x squared plus 1 for those X is
bigger than 0.5 minus 1 for those X's
less than 0.1 so this formula isn't even
continuous divide out by the sum to make
the sum equal to one so it's a
probability distribution and then look
what happens when we do the iterated
convolutions as you can see the Blue
Line the initial distribution wasn't
even continuous but after just a few
iterations we're seeing that same normal
distribution looking shape again
if you think this is cool you should
really get into probability
the theorem I play here is the central
limit theorem and the reason that this
is somehow related to convolutions
is that the distribution of a sum of
independent random variables is given by
the convolution of their distributions
but that's maybe for a different video
in any case I hope you liked fastpow and
importantly I hope this shows you some
of the potential benefits of being able
to take an algorithm and reduce it down
to its fundamental pieces abstract away
the details that you don't really care
about is there some underlying structure
there that makes sense in a more General
context
so while fastpow itself is quite a
simple example some of the craziest most
useful results and very cool
optimizations come from abstracting
things in the same way that we did in
this video
usually with a little more math though
thank you to my patrons and donors for
supporting me
if you liked the video don't forget to
subscribe and if you especially like the
video please consider becoming a patron
on patreon
my company is M coding we do Consulting
Contracting training interview practice
code reviews that kind of thing
if you're interested in working with me
please check out emcoding.io
don't forget to slap that like button
and I'll see you next time